53 Prozent der Deutschen befürchten
einen großen flächendeckenden länger
andauernden Stromausfall im Winter
landläufig Blackout genannt zwar halten
politikverwaltung und die Mehrzahl der
Experten die es für ziemlich
unwahrscheinlich aber niemand kann
hundertprozentig garantieren dass alles
glatt läuft bei der Stromversorgung
sicher ist nur dass wir heute darüber
diskutieren Sorge vor dem Winter wie
wahrscheinlich sind Blackouts jetzt in
der phönix-runde
Phoenix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
hier im Studio Markt elzberg ist bei uns
sie haben einen Bestseller geschrieben
mit dem Titel Blackout morgen ist es zu
spät in dem sie schon vor zehn Jahren
das Szenario eines flächendeckenden
Zusammenbruchs der Stromversorgung und
dessen Folgen entwerfen dieser Roman ist
auch im Jahre 2020
verfilmt worden zugeschaltet ist Sandner
Sandra Kreitner sie sind Krisen und
notfallmanagerin und beraten Kommunen
und Landkreise
Switch ist bei uns sie sind Teamleiterin
Energie in der Redaktion des
Handelsplatz und der Landsberg ist
Hauptgeschäftsführer beim deutschen
Städte und Gemeinde Tag Elsberg sie hat
mir für diesen Bestseller wie gesagt
2012 schon veröffentlicht namens
Blackout eine großen europaweiten
Stromausfall beschrieben sie haben
ausgiebig dazu recherchiert wenn Sie
heute im Abstand vor zehn Jahren auf die
aktuelle Situation sehen wie viel
Realität und wie viel Fiktion steckt
denn in ihrem Roman
Realität steckt insofern drinnen würde
so etwas heute passieren könnte man in
etwa so ein Szenario erwarten wie ich es
im Buch aufzeichne über die Zeit hinweg
was anders ist ist das ja im Buch das
Szenario das schlimmste denkbare ist
nämlich ein Angriff auf die Stromnetze
und das ist nicht worüber wir eigentlich
hier reden wobei in Wahrheit die ersten
Stunden am Tage ist es relativ wurscht
vorher da Ausfall kommt das sind die
Ursache die Folgen immer die gleichen
also das Halten oder auch materielle
Zerstörungen Sprengstoffanschläge ja
durchaus auch möglich sind Landsberg
nehmen wir eigentlich die Gefahr eines
Blackout das muss ja gleich noch
definieren Blackout ist ein er kommt
ohne Vorwarnung flächendeckend und
dauert auch länger als solche Strom
Blackout nehmen wir diese Gefahr zu
wenig ernst oder ist es umgekehrt dass
da vor allen Dingen
Ängste damit geschürt werden dass immer
genau die Frage ich glaube wir müssen
auch solche Szenarien Bedenken keine
Panik machen das deutsche Stromnetz ist
schon relativ sicher aber vor einigen
Jahren hätte auch jemand gesagt also
eine Flutwelle von neun Metern oder zehn
Meter im ATL unvorstellbar vor zwei
Jahren wäre auch jeder Krieg in Europa
unvorstellbar gewesen das heißt wir
müssen Deutschland krisenfester machen
und dazu gehört auch der Blackout oder
man spricht ja bei einer gezielten
Abschaltung von Regionen vom brown-out
um das Netz stabil zu halten das würde
ich nicht ausschließen zumindestens
müssen uns darauf vorbereiten bei uns
funktioniert ja vieles nicht das hat der
warentag vor zwei Jahren gezeigt also
unser Katastrophenschutz ist nach dem
Kalten Krieg immer weiter runtergefahren
worden und da brauchen wir die
zeitenwinde was der Unterschied Blackout
Brown out ist wenn wir gleich noch
genauer erläutern
der Chef des Bundesamtes für
Bevölkerungsschutz und Katastrophenhilfe
der hat in der letzten Woche einen
Blackout als möglich bezeichnet
formuliert also wir müssen uns was
darauf einstellen das ist schon fast
mehr als Möglichkeit
inzwischen ist das Bundesamt
zurückgerudert man haben das so
interpretiert von der Pressestelle dass
der Präsident nur die grundsätzliche
Bedeutung der Vorsorge oder von Vorsorge
hervorheben wollte wir nehmen das jetzt
mal so zu Kenntnisse und lassen uns auf
der Zunge zergehen hat da eine aus Sorge
laut gedacht oder war das eine
kommunikationspfanne nach dem Motto er
war nicht so gemeint wie ich das gesagt
habe vermuten sie ich glaube es war eher
ein weiteres ich glaube es war eine
unbedachte Äußerung denn wer
Landwirtschaft schon gesagt hat der
Katastrophenschutz die Katastrophenhilfe
da muss wirklich nachgebessert werden
aber deswegen darf man einen Blackout
natürlich auch nicht herbei reden und
gerade im Moment wird es so als
politischer Kampfbegriff genutzt und das
ist sehr gefährlich deswegen war dieser
diese misskommunikation nenne ich mal
diese Fehlkommunikation war keine
leichte und das sollte auch nicht
passieren aber Experten halten ein
Blackout für sehr unwahrscheinlich das
muss man immer wieder betonen es kam mir
zu definitionsbegriffsvervierungen würde
ich sagen aber die klären wir gleich
noch oder versuchen Sie zumindest so
gerne von Kreidler sie haben ja zum
Blackout gesagt oder über den Blackout
es geht gar nicht um das Ob sondern die
Frage ist ob um das wann also wann kommt
der Blackout was macht Sie da so sicher
dass er kommt und die bloß nicht wissen
wann
also sicher macht mich da gar nichts ähm
die Sache ist einfach die dass
verschiedene Organisationen Blätter dann
doch als wahrscheinlicher einstufen als
jetzt z.B die Bundesnetzagentur z.B das
Bundesministerium für Landesverteidigung
in Österreich ähm stuft ein Blackout als
wahrscheinlich innerhalb der nächsten
drei Jahre ein und ich denke man sollte
sich gar nicht Gedanken machen ob er
kommt oder oder ob er jetzt in drei
Monaten oder drei Jahren oder 7 Jahren
kommt sondern die ganz wichtige Frage
ist wären wir darauf vorbereitet und da
ist noch sehr viel Luft nach oben das
gilt nicht nur für Österreich es gibt ja
auch für Deutschland die Frage sie hat
uns jetzt gerade schon alle irgendwie
anklingen lassen ist wie wahrscheinlich
ist wir sind noch beim im Bereich des
Blackout die wahrscheinlich ist ein
solcher ich nenne es mal schwerer
Stromausfall wenn es ist richtig
verstanden habe ist ich habe sie auch
vorher schon gesagt auch Experten sind
hier die Verwaltung oder auch
Politikerinnen und Politiker die sagen
also eher unwahrscheinlich ist das so
langsam auf die Seele ein bisschen
Placebo oder gibt es dafür
triftige Anhaltspunkte ganz sicher weiß
man es nicht gibt es triftige
Anhaltspunkte dafür dass uns das
Schlimmste da erspart bleibt ich glaube
wir müssen einmal kurz in die Definition
gehen Blackout ist ein großflächiger
Stromausfall in mehreren Teilen Europas
streng genommen sogar natürlich auch
wenn es in Deutschland dazu kommt es
auch ein Blackout weil wir alle
Zusammenhängen im verbunden jetzt in
Europa würde das natürlich auch andere
Teile Europas im schlimmsten Fall
mitreisen aber das ist wovon wir reden
das ist das Szenario was ja auch Herr
elzberg in seinem Buch so beschrieben
hat im schlimmsten im Worst Case ähm
aber davon reden wir und das ist nicht
ein großflächiger Stromausfall der
innerhalb von wenigen Stunden wieder
erledigt ist sondern das dauert länger
und das halten auch in diesem Winter die
Experten mit denen ich spreche Stromnetz
Experten auch außerhalb der
Bundesnetzagentur unabhängige für sehr
sehr unwahrscheinlich aber man kann es
eben nie sagen dass es nicht passiert
weil es aber Angriff oder sonstige
Unfälle Naturkatastrophen
großflächig können auftreten aber es ist
nicht wahrscheinlicher als in den Jahren
zuvor das zumindest ist die einhellige
Meinung ich halte die Diskussion eben
und da kann ich mich nur anschließend
dem was schon gesagt worden ist über die
Wahrscheinlichkeit für verfehlt das ist
ähnlich wie bei einer Versicherung sie
versicherten sich auch nicht dagegen
dass sie sich in den Finger schneiden
sie schließen aber sehr wohl eine
Versicherung ab für den Fall des
Ablebens oder das Hausbrandes wenn ein
Ereignis eintreten kann dass das Leben
grundlegend bedroht oder auf den Kopf
stellen kann dann schließe ich dagegen
eine Versicherung ab im Fall des
Blackouts ist das eine gewisse Art von
Vorbereitung die man einfach treffen
sollte
Frau kreidner von welchen Stromausfällen
welchen Ausmaßes sprechen sie denn wenn
sie von Strom Ausfällen reden sie
beraten ja auch Gemeinden und und und
Landkreise in Bayern im südlichen Bayern
was was verstehen sie unter Stromausfall
sie haben jetzt auch gesagt diese
Wahrscheinlichkeit haben sie das
österreichische Verteidigungsministerium
passiert was meinen Sie oder was
versteht welches Ausmaß meinen sie
also wenn ich Gemeinden oder oder Kreise
berate dann geht es bei uns wirklich
immer um das Worst Case Szenario
das dieses Worst Case Szenario wenn man
darauf vorbereitet ist dann ist man
automatisch für sehr viele andere Krisen
mit vorbereitet das heißt für regionale
Stromausfälle für rollierende
Stromabschaltungen oder automatischen
Lastabwurf oder sei es mal eine
Unterbrechung der Wasserversorgung der
Kommunikation oder Lieferketten
Unterbrechungen das heißt wenn man
darauf vorbereitet ist kann man sehr
viele andere Krisen sehr gut auch
abarbeiten oder abpuffern und deswegen
beschäftigen wir uns überwiegend eben
mit Blackout als ein Beispiel eines
Worst Case Szenarios um Gemeinden um
Landkreise Krisen fitter zu machen der
kleinere und wesentlich ungefährlichere
Bruder des Blackouts von Anschluss der
braun-out das ist im Unterschied das ist
regional begrenzt
im Prinzip ein Teil des Stromnetzes
vorübergehend abgeschaltet worden
Stabilität zu erhalten und ob da immer
eine Vorwahl
aber da reden wir dann wir haben ja so
eine Situation in Berlin gehabt Köpenick
ist halt großer Stadtteil da hat der
Bagger einen Kabel da waren auch wenn
ich es im Kopf habe 12 14 Stunden
überhaupt kein Strom und das ist auch
schon erheblicher Auswirkungen gehabt
und diese Diskussion die wir jetzt
führen ist ja immer die Angst der
Politik vor der Wahrheit
natürlich ist das sehr unwahrscheinlich
aber es kann es geben ich ich die
Situation in der Ukraine zeigt dass z.B
auch in einem Kriegsfall man vielleicht
versucht als erstes die Stromversorgung
kaputt zu machen ich sage nicht dass das
kommt die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist gering
und wir wollen das auch alle nicht aber
das zu kommunizieren und den Bürgern zu
sagen ist es gibt Situationen da wird
der Staat euch nicht sofort helfen
können und er müsst ihr euch irgendwie
selber helfen können im Alter z.B hat es
auch lange gedauert bis die Hilfskräfte
dort waren und ich glaube das ist die
Aufgabe von Politik auch von Städten und
Gemeinden es gibt nicht die einfache
Lösung wir können nicht so viel
Stromaggregate aufbauen dass das dann
weiter läuft aber wir müssen
zum Beispiel Wissen in einem Landkreis
und einer Stadt wie viel Menschen werden
zu Hause beatmet wir haben das mal
durchgespielt in einem Kreis glauben sie
mal nicht dass sie mal eben die Adressen
von den Leuten kriegen die Krankenhäuser
sagen wir dürfen das nicht sagen aus
Datenschutz können die
Pflegeeinrichtungen sagen Ihnen das
gleiche aber jeder weiß eine solche
Beatmung da ist ein Akku drin nach zwei
Stunden stirbt der Mensch also das sind
Kleinigkeiten und die Geld natürlich
auch beim Braun hat auch so dass es da
auch gesetzliche Regelung dafür gibt
also das heißt das ist ich habe
zumindestens jetzt in der Vorbereitung
gehört auch da muss im Regelfall eine
Vorwarnung sein wenn sie denn möglich
ist das regional begrenzt und auch
zeitlich begrenzt und ich glaube so
maximal im vier Stunden Tag von
Stadtteil zu Stadtteil das ist dann wäre
ja eigentlich auch einigermaßen noch
erträglich das ist das aber nicht wo vor
die Menschen eigentlich Angst haben das
ist in anderen Ländern übrigens auch
Gang und gelbe solche
brown-outsierende Last Abwürfe das haben
wir in anderen Ländern in Europa jedes
Jahr das ist
durchaus Hände war trotzdem mal der
lenzberg recht aber wenn wir darüber
reden über Krisenvorsorge dann ist das
genau richtig was Sie ansprechen aber
das was sie gerade sagt haben mein
Keller ist nämlich das Problem die Leute
haben nicht Angst vor schlechter
Krisenvorsorge die Leute werden gerade
politisch darauf eingestimmt Angst vor
einem Blackout zu haben also vor allem
Szenario vor dem man auch durchaus Angst
haben kann was einem Angst macht und
muss aber das wird ja hier gerade
politisch instrumentalisiert von allen
Seiten und da muss inklusive von der AFD
und das war sehr stark das muss man
immer wieder betonen und ich finde
deswegen ist das Wording ausschlaggebend
also wir müssen nicht von der Gefahr
eines Blackouts reden um die
krisenversorge zu stärken das ist nur
der Punkt den ich gerne machen möchte
gut wahrscheinlich ja und besser zu
Händel ist ein brown-out Frau Kreitner
als ein Stunden weißes Abschalten der
Infrastruktur wir haben es jetzt gerade
schon gesagt also regional begrenzt
zeitlich begrenzt es ist möglicherweise
kann man die Menschen auch noch Vorwand
was welche welchen Einfluss hat denn zum
ein solcher brown-out also wenn er nur
vier Stunden in Betrieben oder in
Privathaushalten herrscht und dann in
den nächsten Stadtteil wandert wer
welchen Einfluss hat er auf die
Funktionsfähigkeit der Infrastruktur
kann man dazu was sagen
auch also nicht nur den Betrieben
sondern auch eine Privathaushalten
ich denke das wird massiv unterschätzt
gerade im Bereich der kritischen
Infrastruktur und gerade auch im Bereich
der Produktion weil man rechnet ja damit
dass das dann nicht nur ein Tag lang
geht sondern dass das wirklich mehrere
Tage oder Wochen anhalten könnte und das
heißt zum Beispiel produzieren die
Betriebe die nicht darauf vorbereitet
sind in Deutschland weil wir eine sehr
hohe Versorgungssicherheit haben würden
dann die Produktionen herunterfahren und
erstmal abwarten bis die Stromversorgung
wieder gesichert ist also die fahren
nicht jeden Tag die Produktion hoch und
wieder runter das ist einfach nicht
realistisch und das gleiche ist auch im
Bereich der Pflege zum Beispiel
ambulante Pflegedienste sind nicht drauf
vorbereitet die analysezentren sind auch
sowas nicht vorbereitet und auch
pflegeheime sind nicht vorbereitet dass
ähm immer mal tagsweise stundenweise
dann der Strom weg ist wie muss man sich
denn das Vorstellen wir reden jetzt also
von diesem brown-out also ein
gesteuerter einigermaßen
kontrollierbarer Stromausfall über einen
längeren Zeitraum aber abwechseln
unterschiedlich
Stromausfall Abschaltung Ausfall ist
schon wieder Kontrollverlust oben
Stromausfall zu vermeiden wir sagen
jetzt gar nicht mal wozu was da die
Ursachen sein könnten also gut
Stromabschaltung
Frau Kreitner da ist ja immer die Frage
was fällt wie wann aus das will ja nicht
alles gleichzeitig also die Heizung
fällt wahrscheinlich gleichzeitig aus
die Trinkwasserversorgung fällt nicht
gleich aus die Geldautomaten
möglicherweise funktionieren auch noch
eine Zeit lang Tankstelle werden
irgendwann mal keine Pumpen mehr haben
also funktionierende Pumpen fürs Tanken
was fällt denn da wann aus wie muss man
sich das vorstellen ist das dann so eine
Kettenreaktion äh nacheinander fallen
die ganzen Lebensgrundlagen weg
also bei den rollierenden
Stromabschaltungen ist es so dass
natürlich zuerst im Computer zum
Beispiel ausfallen zu Hause das Licht
geht aus kann man sich vorstellen
natürlich man kann auch nicht mehr
tanken dann wenn man in den zwei Stunden
oder vier Stunden gerade tanken möchte
ist das nicht möglich man kann kein Geld
abheben die Supermärkte die nicht
vorgesorgt haben die keine
Notstromversorgung haben da fallen die
Kassensysteme aus Handynetz hängt dann
davon ab wie groß die Gebiete sind die
abgeschalteten werden aber da kann es
auch dazu kommen dass auch die
handykommunikation dann ausfällt also es
hat schon auch Auswirkungen aber ich
möchte auch immer wieder betonenden
Stromausfall ist für die meisten von uns
auch nichts lebensgefährliches ja es ist
nichts was eigentlich also bedrohlich
sein sollte ja also man kann das gut
händeln wenn man entsprechend auch ein
bisschen vorbereitet ist daheim und auch
entsprechend in den kritischen
Infrastrukturen man muss sich einfach
vorab Gedanken dazu machen und halt dann
Maßnahmen ergreifen also nochmal
Blackout Stromausfall brown- keine
Stromabschaltung eine gezielte
Stromabschaltung die wird gibt es ja
meistens dann wenn die Stabilität des
Stromnetzes nicht mehr gewährleistet ist
sie muss ja immer 50 Herz haben wenn das
unterschritten wird dann muss zur
Stabilisierung des Netzes müssen muss
Strom abgeschaltet werden das ist der
eigentlich der der eigentliche
Anlass für diese Stromabschaltung woher
kommt denn diese diese unterbelastung
des Stromnetzes ja das kann verschiedene
Gründe haben gerade im kommenden Winter
Probleme geben wenn es zu kalt wird wenn
wir zu viel Sturm im Norden haben etc
also das das können vielfältige Gründe
sein warum es dazu kommt
letztendlich
ist hier glaube ich entscheiden dass und
das sagen uns zumindest die Experten für
den kommenden Winter das in den
allermeisten Fällen wenn der Winter
nicht zu kalt wird wir eine
halbwegs sichere Versorgung haben
sollten
ein Szenario das dass wir jetzt zum
Beispiel angeschnitten dass das
womöglich mehrere Wochen dauert selbst
das ist für den kommenden Winter da
müsst zum Beispiel sehr sehr kalt werden
über längere Zeit also das heißt bei
diesem Braunau dieser sturmabschaltung
müssen verschiedene Komponenten
zusammenkommen da kann man ja schon
vorschlagen treffen also wenn ein
Kälteeinbruch droht wir haben ja im
Moment sondern inzwischen sehr sichere
Wettervorhersagen jedenfalls
kurzfristige oder wenn die Fragen Soßen
signalisieren es gibt zu wenig Strom aus
unseren AKWs dann es sind ja im Prinzip
die Kommunen die Landkreise die Stelle
da schon drauf vorbereitet und können
entsprechende Vorkehrung treffen ja die
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber halten das ja
auch alles von oben sage ich mal im
Blick und die haben auch tägliche
Sitzungen wo die genau das schon eine
Woche im Voraus versuchen mit
Wetterprognosen mit
nachfrageangebotsprognosen festzustellen
deswegen redet man vom brownouts
natürlich können kann das auch mal
vorkommen vielleicht in anderen Ländern
dass sie ohne Vorankündigung passieren
aber in der Regel gehen die
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber in Deutschland
davon aus dass sie das vorher sehen dass
sie das ankündigen können dass sie
maximal vier Stunden dauern und das dann
diese diese über- oder Unterlass die die
im Netz vorhergesehen wird auch übrigens
auf ganz Deutschland regional runter
tröpfelt verteilt wird also es wird dann
in sehr sehr kleinen Kaskaden nur
Auswirkungen haben das heißt vielleicht
ist es in Berlin ein Teil von
Friedrichshain oder ein Teil von
irgendeinem anderen Stadtteil und dann
rolliert das so war das gemeint und
selbst das Halten eben aufgrund der
milden Wetterprognosen die Experten
mittlerweile für gar nicht mehr so
wahrscheinlich weil haben wir einen
milden Winter erwarten aber ja wenn sich
das ändert wir können ja auch viel dafür
tun als Einzelpersonen um das in Grenzen
zu halten die Probleme die Heizlüfter
sind ja wie warm ist Semmel über die
Baumarkt und Einrichtungshäuser tägen
gegangen das sieht ja wahre Stromfresser
die eigentlich der Stromausfälle
vielleicht nicht aber die Notwendigkeit
einer Stromabschaltung erst
wahrscheinlich machen ja das ist ein
bisschen ironisch leider also im
Baumarkt werden sie gerade immer noch
überall angepriesen gehen auch immer
noch wie war eine Semmel über die Theke
Gott sei Dank haben wir den Zustand dass
sie Gasspeicher 100% voll sind die Leute
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so panisch
sind dass sie dass sie in die Gasheizung
ausgeht aber ich möchte gerne mal
betonen dass Gas immer noch
günstiger ist auf die Kilowattstunde
gesehen als Strom im Moment also diese
Heizlüfter sind auch und das haben viele
Menschen im Alter glaube ich auch
erfahren
wahnsinnig Strom fressen also wer die
anmacht um Geld zu sparen der wird sein
blaues Wunder erleben nächstes Jahr das
ist leider nicht
zielführend aber es sind 800.000
verkauft worden wenn die alle
gleichzeitig laufen dann haben wir ein
echtes Problem gut ich meine die haben
wir vielleicht auch zu Hause schon
welche gehabt das ist nicht ganz
Deutschland gleichzeitig ganz
Deutschland gleichzeitig kalt aber wenn
das eine größere Fläche ist mit mehreren
Großstädten dann kann das schon Probleme
geben
gerade gesagt so in den Nebensatz die
Frau Kreitner ja zum Thema noch äh zum
zum Heizlüftern wobei diese genau die
Heizlüfter wurden auch in den Stress
dass der Übertragungsnetzbetreiber mit
einberechnet schon ja also da muss man
wirklich keine Angst haben dass das dann
dazu führt dass es Netz lahm liegt nur
weil die Heizlüfter ans Netz gehen also
das wurde von den übertragungsnetzwerk
Betreibern bereits mit einem berechnet
die haben das auf dem Schirm
gesagt ähm die Leute sollen sich oder
dürfen sich immer nur auf die Gemeinden
auf die Kommunen verlassen die müssen
auch selbst etwas tun aber das ist ja
genau die Erwartungshaltung wenn ein ob
jetzt eine Abschaltung oder im
schlimmsten Fall der Stromausfall
passiert dass tatsächlich die Kommunen
dann eine Notfallplan haben mit dem sie
die Bevölkerung unterstützen wenn das
nur kurzfristige Ausfälle sind der
Kühlschrank geht dabei nicht kaputt es
genügend Wasser und Konservendosen zu
Hause dann spielt das keine Rolle aber
bei den längeren Zeitraum sehr wohl kann
man sich nicht auf seine Kommune
verlassen sondern Situation natürlich
kann man sie auf seine Kommune verlassen
das ist ja auch so dass die Kommunen
insgesamt das werden Sie sicherlich
bestätigen können sich schon auf den Weg
machen mit krisenstäben auch die Länder
machen sehr viel ich weiß dass das
Nordrhein-Westfalen da werden Tanklager
geschaffen für Polizei und Feuerwehr es
werden Vorräte angelegt aber das ist ein
Prozent der würde ich sagen realistisch
in den letzten vier fünf Monaten läuft
und es gibt eben letztlich kein
überregionales Krisenmanagement das
haben wir im Aatal gesehen also wenn
eine Schadenslage Eintritt die eine
Ländergrenze in Deutschland
überschreitet da haben sie ein riesen
Problem und wenn es eine ist die Meere
Länder aber dann haben sie das nächste
unintelligible Problem deswegen sage ich
wir brauchen eigentlich auf der
Bundesebene eine nationalen Krisenstab
und auf der Länderebene eingegebenen
falls auch
länderübergreifenden Krisenstab damit
wir wir so schön heißt vor die Lage
kommen brauchen wir denn in den
Gemeinden kein doch natürlich das haben
wir ja auch nur wenn die Gemeinde im
Aatal nicht weiß dass
110 km weiter der Fluss sich staut weil
der Nordrhein-Westfalen ist dann nützt
den das nicht das ist eine
informationsfrage es ändert aber nichts
an der Tatsache dass wir den Leuten
einfach auch mehr Vorsorge ich sag das
jetzt mal ein bisschen erzieherisch
beibringen müssen es gibt seit Jahren
diese Liste des BBK was sollte man haben
also für 14 Tage Wasser eine
Taschenlampe die mit Batterie läuft
vielleicht ein Akku Kerzen ein bisschen
was zu essen früher hat das kein
Menschen interessiert das auch
interessant ein Ergebnis dieser
Diskussion das können sich runterladen
und Sie können es als Broschüre im BBK
bestellen Moment ist die Broschüre
vergriffen also das ist
so ein Gefühl also
fragen wir haben jetzt den wahren Tag am
8 Dezember machen sie meine Umfrage auf
der Straße wer weiß eigentlich welcher
signalto bedeutet was das wissen die
Leute nicht und das hat sich auch im
Alter gezeigt die Leute sind in den
Keller gegangen bei Hochwasser und sind
gestorbenweise im Keller noch was regeln
wollten wir sind wir haben das nie
eingeübt und das muss besser werden weil
auch immer alles zur Verfügung stellen
und wenn man alles funktioniert
Supermarkt gegangen jetzt haben weil sie
gesagt haben da gibt es auch auf
kommunaler Ebene entsprechende Vorsorge
unsere Kollegen von Report Mainz vom
Südwestrundfunk ja eine Umfrage gemacht
unter den deutschen Landkreisen und
Kommunen also auch in ihrem Landsberg da
haben etwa die Hälfte der Gemeinden und
und Städte geantwortet dass etwa die
Hälfte nämlich 101 dieser Gemeinden und
Landkreise keinen funktionsfähigen
Notfallplan haben nach denen Auskunft 78
haben keine notbrunnen obwohl der glaube
ich grundsätzlich vorgeschrieben ist für
die
nottrinkwasserversorgung und 67 keine
Anlaufstelle in der Gemeinde wo man sich
hinwenden kann was soll ich jetzt tun
was passiert können Sie mich informieren
das sind ja eigentlich relativ
ernüchternde zahlen das sind ganz
ernüchterne zahlen wobei das hat
natürlich eine große Welle ausgelöst in
der kommunalen Familie der hat gesagt
weil die haben die Frage falsch gestellt
ich sage das nur der ist nämlich
angeblich teilweise gefragt worden haben
sie einen Krisenstab bei denen heißt er
aber nicht Krisenstab sondern der heißt
bei den notfallstab also haben gesagt
haben wir nicht mal drauf kommen können
dass das gemeint ist gar kein Problem
also da gibt es Defizite die Defizite
müssen wir lösen die müssen auch die
Kommunen lösen das schaffen sie aus
meiner Sicht nicht alleine wir brauchen
da einen Bündnis für den zivilen
Katastrophenschutz von bundländern und
Kommunen wir müssen auch mal drüber
reden welche Rolle spielt eigentlich die
Bundeswehr wir haben ja diese klare
Trennung zwischen äußeren und inneren
Angelegenheiten aus
verfassungsrechtlichen Gründen
funktioniert das denn eigentlich in der
corona-krise hat das nicht funktioniert
19000 Partner haben über 20 Millionen
Arbeitsstunden leisten müssen weil der
zivile Schutz versagt hat und im Aartal
darf ich mal daran erinnern die
Feuerwehr hatte kein einziges
wattfähiges Fahrzeug das ist jetzt kein
Vorwurf an Rheinland-Pfalz ist ein
anderen Ländern genauso oder denken Sie
an die Waldbrände wer fliegt denn da und
löscht das ist entweder die Bundeswehr
ab und zu mal die Polizei der zivile
Katastrophenschutz hat das nicht und das
müssen wir insgesamt anders angehen das
ist mindestens genauso wichtig wie
natürlich und der Bundeswehr er ist auch
eine Frage der das Bewusstseins der
Menschen ist jetzt hier so angeklungen
jahrzehntelang haben wir die sogenannte
Friedensdividende genossen da kann
nichts passieren wir sind alles Elend
alle Katastrophen dieser Welt sind weit
weg manchmal passiert es auch bei uns
Tierarzt aber ist kein Vergleich mit
seinen Zone oder den Inselstaaten im
Pazifik wir leben da hier auf einer
Insel der Seligen dieses Bewusstsein und
kann nichts passieren oder das auch nie
gelernt zu haben das ist Katastrophen
das ist Aufnahme Situationen geben der
Hand ist das eines der größten Hemmnisse
bei der Bewältigung dieser Frage jetzt
sicher ich bin ja zum Beispiel noch aus
einer Generation die zu den den das Ende
des Kalten Krieges noch mitbekommen hat
damals hat man da ein ganz anderes
Bewusstsein gehabt noch diesbezüglich
mit 89 würde ich sagen hat das so
begonnen zu verschwinden
und was ich ganz interessant fand in dem
Kontext seit Erscheinen des Buches
beispielsweise vor zehn Jahren war ich
wirklich bei hunderten Veranstaltungen
verschiedenster Art von Bürgermeister
bis zur EU gekommen ist an Unternehmen
Behörden etc das Bewusstsein über die
Jahre ja gewachsen ist aber leider
Bewusstsein alleine reicht noch nicht
wegen dem dann keine Handlungen folgen
also das muss scheinbar immer etwas
passieren damit was passiert und mir
kommt vor dass da jetzt natürlich die
Pandemie schon mal sehr viel geholfen
hat wenn wir von Vorbereitung z.B
sprechen ich erinnere nur an die Tage
nach dem Beginn des ersten lockdowns ich
sage nur Nudeln und Klopapier ne da
merkt man dann plötzlich ach ja gar
nicht doof wenn man was zu Hause gehabt
hätte für ein paar Tage einen hätte man
nicht panisch die Klopapier egal es muss
ja nicht immer der Blackout sein so ein
Grundvoraussetzung unserer Gesellschaft
du musst noch ein paar Tage krank werden
meinetwegen oder eingeschneit werden
obwohl das mit dem Kind mit der
Klimakrise immer seltener wird aber
natürlich die Klimakrise
werden die die Bargeldautomaten
aufmunitionieren das ist ja glaube ich
im Sommer in Berlin passiert dass wir
sofort auf und gleich unangenehm auf das
weiß noch relativ harmlos mit dem was
uns da blühen könnte Frau Kreitner jetzt
werden ja Politikerinnen und Politiker
auch auf der kommunal Ebene gewählt
Verantwortung zu übernehmen
vorausschauend zu halten Schaden von der
Bevölkerung zu nehmen sie sind Beraterin
bei diesen Kommunen und Landkreisen in
Südbayern ist da das Bewusstsein auf der
politischen Ebene oder wie man so schön
sagt in der politischen Klasse schon so
weit gedient dass jetzt inzwischen die
Gefahr erkannt haben dass man
zumindestens vorbereitet sein muss auch
wenn dann hoffentlich nichts passiert
also das ist nicht nur in der Politik
der Fall ich sehe das seit einem halben
Jahr das auf allen Ebenen eigentlich das
Risiko Bewusstsein geweckt wird das doch
Dinge passieren können die man nie
erwartet hätte und tatsächlich wenn
dieses Risiko Bewusstsein mal da ist und
man ein bisschen unterstützt dann gehen
die Leute und auch die Politiker und
auch die kritischen Infrastrukturen
tatsächlich in die Umsetzung also ich
sehe das hier in Oberbayern und Schwaben
das ist von der Kreisebene
runtergebrochen auf
Blaulichtorganisationen auf die
Gemeinden Ebenen dass tatsächlich sehr
viele auch die Konzepte umsetzen um
insgesamt Krisen fitter zu werden ja
also ich glaube vielen ist klar diese
krisenfreien Zeiten die wir hatten das
muss nicht auch immer so weitergehen ja
und ähm viele merken jetzt auch okay bei
überregionalen Katastrophen kommt
erstmal keine Hilfe von außen das heißt
man ist auf sich gestellt und dann wäre
es schon klug vorzusorgen also ich war
heute zum Beispiel bei einer Gemeinde
und die Bürgermeisterin hat zu mir
gesagt ja wissen Sie wir alle dass er
nichts passiert aber ich bin ein Mensch
ich bin lieber vorbereitet dass wenn der
Fall eintritt wir das gut handhaben
können als das eine Situation kommt und
wir gar keine Vorbereitung haben keine
Anlaufstellen für die Bevölkerung keine
Ahnung wie wir Krisenstab bilden sollen
also lieber vorsorgen denn egal was dann
kommt dann sind wir vorbereitet also
wenn das jetzt der Bürgermeister oder
was wieder gesagt hat und das war
kneipner da erlebt hat das ist ja
entweder die Vogel strauß-politik den
Kopf ins anzustecken wird schon nichts
passieren oder das sogenannte flank
Florians Prinzip heiliger ST Florian
verschoben mein Haus sind andere an aber
diese Einstellung
ist die doch
verbreitet auch aus ihrer Praxis
vielleicht heraus zu sagen dass man sagt
naja also es wird bei uns nicht
passieren also es gibt beides das
Bewusstsein ist gestiegen das hat er die
Umfrage auch ergeben es wird sicherlich
da auch über den Gesetzgeber auch
Bundesland ist eben noch mal Vorgaben
geben aber muss auch mal ehrlich sein
wenn sie im Wahlkampf stehen und auf
jeden Fall der alternative ich mache mir
für Katastrophenschutz oder neuen
Kindergarten wir wird in der Wähler wohl
entscheiden im Moment ist das ein Thema
und da sagen ja auch 53 Prozent da muss
was geschehen ich will geschützt werden
reden wir noch mal in drei Monaten
können Sie ein schönes Beispiel nehmen
nach der Flutkatastrophe im Ahrtal sind
diese
universalschadensversicherung durch die
Decke gegangen die Leute wollten alle
versichert sein gegen alles und wie ist
es jetzt genauso wie vorher also das
Gedächtnis ist da auch kurz insofern bin
ich nicht so sicher ob es anhält aber es
ist eine Aufgabe der Politik dafür zu
sorgen klar aber wenn es so schwierig es
wird immer erst eine Schmerzgrenze
überschritten sein muss bevor etwas
wirklich passiert und es Bewusstsein
rückt vielleicht auch irreversibel ins
bewusstseindrückt ist das ja auch
schwierig welche Möglichkeiten hat die
Politik da eigentlich noch außer
sozusagen wir sind im Wahlkampf und der
Kindergarten ist für viele auch wichtig
ne also ich glaube dass wir brauchen
Kommunikationskonzepte keine Panik
machen das haben sie völlig richtig
gesagt aber zu sagen wir tun alles damit
Ihr in solchen Situation Boden geschützt
seid ihr müsst wissen wenn der Strom
ausfällt und sind es noch fünf Stunden
wie melde ich denn die Oma hat ein
Herzinfarkt gekriegt wo gehe ich denn
hin das ist ja jetzt keine große
finanzielle Aufwand es gibt größere
Dinge da wird es komplizierter und auch
das was das BBK ja aus meiner Sicht
wirklich toll macht nur es ist nicht in
den Hinterköpfen der Menschen es müsste
auch mal im Kino laufen kommunikation
ist alles aber auch in dem Bereich ist
Kommunikation ganz wesentlich und da
müsste mehr geschehen und da sollte
Politik auch mal den Mut haben es hat
zum Beispiel vor einigen Jahren man
Diskussion gegeben ob man nicht mal eine
große Übung macht eine große Übung
fiktiv ein Flugzeug stürzt über
Frankreich ab jetzt muss gar nicht
Terror sein soll sie haben weil es in
der Mitte der Stadt abstürzt sechs oder
zehntausend verletzte wie organisiere
ich das dass die versorgt werden dass
die Abtransport wir wer hat den Hut auf
welche Rolle spielt die Bundeswehr die
Polizei und ähnlich ist das ist dann
nicht gemacht worden wie ich weiß wenn
man sagt wir wollen die Bevölkerung
nicht beunruhigen und das ist auch
wichtig wir müssen die Dinge üben und
zwar nicht nur abstrakt sondern auch hin
und wieder mal
also die Leute nicht beunruhigen ist das
eine Panikmache das Stichwort viel auch
schon wie sieht es denn damit aus
schwierig das die kommunikative Frage
wurde ja gerade am Anfang schon
angeschnitten man hat das Feld hier
leider
den rechten überlassen zur Panikmache
tut dann meiner Meinung nach zum Teil
ein überkompensieren in die andere
Richtung überhaupt keine Gefahr was was
auch wiederum ein Problem ist aber es
ist ja generell in unserer Diskurs
Kultur heutzutage wahnsinnig geschrieben
noch eine vernünftige Diskussion zu
finden also ich möchte auch nicht der
Politiker sein der auch vernünftige Art
und Weise im momentan da draußen die
Bevölkerung informiert ähm es wird
jedesmal irgendeine Agenda dahinter
vermutet wenn ein Unternehmen sagt bitte
bereit war dann heißt sicher die wollen
nur Geld damit verdienen egal welcher
Politiker sagt wird man irgendeine
Agentin also ich muss gestehen dass das
ist momentan sehr sehr schwierig zu
kommen wenn manche
Diskussionsbeiträge in Social Media
Kanälen auch nicht unbedingt hilfreich
Stichwort ist noch bei meiner Abteilung
Panik mache Rolle der Medien was ist wie
ist das da in diesem ganzen Kontext
einzuschätzen ja ich finde das
tatsächlich viele Medien dieser
Panikmacher auch an heimfallen gerade
muss ich sagen also ich
es kommt halt immer darauf an wie man
Fragen stellt also wenn man jetzt was
dazu schreibt oder ein Beitrag
formuliert wie wahrscheinlich ist ein
Blackout kann man das machen wenn man
darüber auch die Informationen raus gibt
die ja Landsberg zum Beispiel waren also
wie bereite ich mich denn vor wie kann
ich dann trotzdem Notruf absetzen also
dass man das alles ins richtige Licht
drückt aber nicht sagt na ja wenn hier
im Blackout kommt dann aber gute Nacht
liebe Freunde und dann ist ganz
Deutschland
geht vor die Hunde das ist natürlich
überhaupt nicht hilfreich und ich glaube
was die Politik schon gemacht hat und
was ein guter und wichtiger Schritt ist
gerade mit Blick auf das was im Alter
passiert ist ist das am 8 Dezember ja
auch zum ersten Mal diese Warnungen aufs
Handy gespielt werden ne das ist das ist
ein unheimlich großer Schritt ins glaube
ich ohne dass sie nicht gegeben hätte
und ähm dass da sowas ist sehr sehr
wichtig und mit so einem warmen Tag und
mit dem dass die Leute auch damit
konfrontiert werden auf Ihrem Smartphone
und ich glaube
[Musik]
um Aufmerksamkeit zu erregen nehmen wir
das Beispiel dieser Aussage von vor ein
paar Tagen wo der Chef des BWK gesagt
hat wir müssen uns im Winter womöglich
auf Blackout vor zu vorbereiten und dann
nachgeschoben hat im selben Interview
wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe mit
Blackout meine ich gezielte regionale
Abschaltung also eigentlich hat er nicht
vom Blackout gesprochen
wahnsinnig ungeschickt formuliert wenn
ich aber als Medium mit hergehe und sag
was meinen Sie jetzt eigentlich meinen
sie Blackout oder Abschaltung wie sollen
wir denn das jetzt kommunizieren könnte
ich machen oder ich gehe einfach hin und
sagt Fahrrad Blackout gesagt
warnt vor Blackouts im Winter war glaube
ich die Überschriften genau das ist der
Punkt genau und wer weiter gelesen hat
gesagt er hat eigentlich vor womöglich
ein bisschen kann ich als Medium jetzt
sagen okay sie haben ja eigentlich
Abschaltungen gemeint dann schreibe ich
Abschaltung in der Umgang aber das
interessiert natürlich wieder in zu
korrigieren an der Stelle muss man auch
sagen es war sehr sehr unglücklich bis
unprofessionell das so zu kommentieren
aber ich muss jetzt dann nicht immer
unbedingt auch noch als Band verstärken
in der Öffentlichkeit auch kaum bekannt
ist dass dieses besagte BBK außer im
Kriegsfall ja gar keine Befugnis hat das
ist eine reine Beratungsfunktion ich
halte das für falsch ich glaube dass dem
bestimmten Katastrophenlagen auch eine
Weisungsbefugnis haben sollten ich weiß
dass die Länder dann sagen hier wir sind
auch zuständig die Kommunen auch aber
darüber muss auch gesprochen werden aber
das ist eine Frage des Gesetzgebers gut
das damit ähm kratzen wir am Prinzip ist
Föderalismus eigene Sendung
aus ihrer Praxis auch so jetzt die Leute
also sie kommen ja mit vielen Menschen
zusammen dass da Angst vorherrscht oder
ist das eher so eine Art Vorsicht oder
dass man irgendwie nicht genau weiß oder
jetzt wirklich Angst zu haben schon gar
keine Panik welche wie reagieren die
Leute gerade jetzt in der Frage war
jetzt ein kälter Einbruch kriegen wir
noch genügend Gas kriegen wir noch
genügend Strom
also die Leute also ich habe bisher noch
niemanden gesehen der jetzt hier
irgendwie in Panik ausgebrochen ist ja
ähm wir hatten hier jetzt in Bayern auch
viele Sensibilisierungen was bedeutet
das die Behörden Gemeinden und auch
Kreise die Bevölkerung darauf
hingewiesen haben dass da ein Risiko ist
ja und das ist Sinn macht Notfall
Vorräte anzulegen was wir gesehen haben
ist das sehr viele Leute das dann
tatsächlich machen also die Supermärkte
sind relativ leer es heißt aber nicht
dass das deswegen panikäufe sind sondern
die Leute gehen dann mit den Checklisten
einkaufen und gehen damit auch
vernünftig um also da heißt es dann im
Ort ja der netto ist heute leer wegen
der Aktion gehst halt morgen wieder
einkaufen also die kriegen das wirklich
sehr gut auch hin selbst wenn da
Informationen stattfinden das ist das
eine und auch bei den Vorträgen oder
auch auf kreisebenen und auf
gemeindeebenen habe ich bisher nie
jemanden gehabt der dann irgendwie ganz
panisch wurde also ich
es ist verständlich wenn man sich mit
Worst Case Szenarien befasst dass man
erstmal ein ungutes Gefühl hat aber die
Sache ist die man hat es ja in der Hand
man kann ja vorsorgen und das ist ja das
Gute daran und mit jedem Schritt den man
mehr vorsorgt ist man auch beruhigt da
ja also ich meine ich setze mich ja auch
ins Auto und schneide mich an weil ich
dann beruhigter bin sollte ein Unfall
passieren ja und das gleiche ist es auch
mit der Krisenvorsorge und da möchte
schreiben kriege weil ich da in der
Diskussion drin dass die Leute mir
schreiben ja ich ich bin Mieter ich habe
eine ganz kleine Wohnung ich habe keinen
Keller wo soll ich denn für zwei Wochen
wasserstapeln andere sagen ich habe gar
kein Geld diese Vorräte zu schaffen das
ist auch nicht so ganz ohne wir leben ja
nicht alle in dem Einfamilienhaus in
Bayern oder in einer schönen Wohnung wo
Platz ist auch da muss man nachdenken in
solchen Krisensituationen das heißt es
wird wahrscheinlich auch
regional Depots geben müssen wo man
bestimmte Dinge die dann vielleicht auch
haltbar ist vorher halten aber ich
möchte dass also jeder hat auch eine
Eigenverantwortung zur Vorsorge und ich
ähm glaube nicht dass man die ganze
Verantwort an die Politik oder Kommunen
abgeben kann dass das nicht funktioniert
haben wir im Ahrtal gesehen da waren die
Leute mehrere Tage auf sich gestellt
hatten hätten sich gewünscht sie hätten
all diese Vorräte zu Hause gehabt an der
Stelle aber ich glaube es ist so ein
bisschen fifty-fifty also man muss auch
an die Leute selbst appellieren damit
Umsicht mit Vorsicht sich vorzubereiten
und man kann nicht alles abwälzen glaube
ich das muss man ganz klar betonen
ein Gesichtspunkt würde ich gerne mal
bringen wir müssen natürlich noch
vielleicht darf ich noch ganz kurz was
dazu sagen zu den kleinen Wohnungen und
zum kleinen Budget es ist zum einen
nicht so dass man gleich den
krisenvorrat komplett einkaufen gehen
muss also wir empfehlen das auch Schritt
für Schritt wir haben eine Infokampagne
Schritt für Schritt krisenfit das heißt
bei jedem Einkauf nimmt man ein bisschen
was von der Liste mit ja die Supermärkte
sind auch man kann wirklich jetzt sich
über die Zeit langsam auch in
krisenvorrat zulegen das ist das eine
zum zum kleinen Geldbeutel und das
zweite ist auch bei kleinen Wohnungen
wenn man wirklich möchte ja dann findet
man Platz man findet vielleicht unterm
Bett kann man vielleicht ein bisschen
Wasserflaschen reinmachen oder neben die
Jeans hat noch haben noch nudelpackungen
Platz und ein bisschen riesenvorrat ist
immer noch besser als gar keiner da
macht man halt nur für 10 Tage ja das
ist besser als nichts also man muss da
ein bisschen kreativ auch sein und nicht
stark nach nach Liste ich muss jetzt ähm
für meine vier Personen 20 Kilo
Getreideprodukte 18 Kilo Gemüse und
Hülsenfrüchte und so weiter auf einmal
einkaufen also das denke ich
kann man auch einfach Schritt für
Schritt machen und man sollte einfach
das Einkaufen was man so auch gerne ist
und dementsprechend dann einfach wieder
rollieren verbrauchen und nachkaufen
jetzt haben wir ja von eher Milten
Auswirkungen eines komfortverzichts
durch weniger Strom oder zeitweise kein
Strom gesprochen es gibt die gäbe ja
noch andere Ursachen als das jetzt
aufgrund der nicht vorhandenen
Netzspannung Strom ausfällt dann
Stichwort Terra Akte
Sprengstoffanschläge selber Attacken ist
das dann dann sind sie aber in diesem in
diesem Bereich das Einkommen den große
Schwierigkeiten das um vielleicht die
Szenario noch ganz kurz mal zu
differenzieren wir haben über das Braun
und geschaffen die zielte Abschaltung
regional kurz Stromausfall auch eher
regional auch nicht zu lang aber halt
ein bisschen Kontrollverlust das nächste
wäre ein normaler Blick hat weil nicht
absichtlicherweise geführt da werden
Ihnen die Energieexperten rundherum
sagen selbst wenn es dazu kommt hat man
sowas binnen Stunden bis maximal im
schlimmsten Fall für manche Gebiete drei
vier Tage war seine Katastrophe ist für
die Gebiete unter Kontrolle
was anderes ist wenn wenn jemand bewusst
versucht die Netze unten zu halten das
ist das Szenario meines Buches das ist
im weiteren aber terrorkrieg mit
gewissen Mitteln unter anderem das
Blackouts wir sehen das jetzt in der
Ukraine dann sind wir in einer ganz
anderen Situation da helfen dir auch die
Vorbereitung für die nächsten 10 14 Tage
nur sehr bedingt muss man auch klar
Differenzierung dass das ja höchst
unterschiedliche Ursachen auch haben
kann jetzt ist es ja so
Stromausfall Stromabschaltung ist schon
unangenehm wenn man den Strompreis nicht
bezahlen kann auch das geht jetzt ein
bisschen weg von dem Thema vielleicht
zum Schluss der Sendung strompreisbremse
das scheint eine höchst komplizierte
Angelegenheit zu werden möglicherweise
hilft sie gar nicht so sehr
den Eindruck würde ich jetzt nicht so
unterstreichen Wirkung kommt entweder
gar nicht oder zu spät es ist auch sehr
komplex gemacht wird vielleicht eher mit
Einmalzahlungen laufen sollen
es ist es ist sehr komplex aber mit
Einmalzahlungen hätte man die
Strompreise sind über einen längeren
Zeitraum werden die auf diesem hohen
Niveau bleiben ich glaube Einmalzahlung
hätten nicht gereicht und ja es ist
komplex aber so wie es jetzt aufgebaut
ist ist ähm mit Blick auf die Zeit die
beste Alternative sie hätte in meinen
Augen früher kommen müssen definitiv
jetzt müssen die Leute erstmal gucken
wie sie bis März beim Strom zumindest
über die Runden kommen dann geht es ja
rückwirkend ab Januar aber ich glaube
wichtig ist dass der dass der sparenreiz
erhalten bleibt eben kompliziert ist
beim Gas
ich finde das nicht unbedingt Computer
als beim Gas ist eigentlich
verabschiedet worden ist von der Politik
die strompreisbremse
also eigentlich also heute kam ja der
Gesetzentwurf wo beides Finale die
Eckpunkte kamen wo beides final wurde
länger gedauert als strompreisbremse
vielleicht weil die die Erlös
Abschöpfung damit dran hängt aber
eigentlich vom Prinzip her geht läuft
beides gleich ab beim Strom fällt
entfällt nur die Einmalzahlung im
Dezember aber ansonsten ist sich das
relativ ähnlich bis auf die Uhr Beträge
natürlich und die Gaspreise sind
natürlich viel schneller explodiert ne
die Strompreise steigen aber niemals so
drastisch wie die Gaspreise und ich
finde schon man kann natürlich da würde
ich Ihnen auch recht geben die Politiker
dem April sich schon auf dem Weg machen
müssen aber es ist schon hoffnungssignal
und dass das ganz komplizierte Vorgänger
ist das muss man verstehen ich glaube
viele Menschen empfinden das als
Hoffnung und das ist auch schon was in
diesem Krisenzeiten gut das damit sind
wir am Ende dieser Sendung ganz bestimmt
nicht mit diesem Thema Mark Elsberg
bedanke mich
Alexandra Kreitner bei Katrin wietsch
und bei Gerd Landsberg Liebe
ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer morgen in
der Phönix Runde Kompromiss beim
Bürgergeld wer hat sich durchgesetzt
wahrscheinlich wird morgen live in der
Phönix Runde auch das Ergebnis bekannt
gegeben werden und am spätestens am
Freitag dann von Bundesrat und Bundestag
verabschiedet sein damit das Bürgergeld
zum ersten Januar in Kraft treten kann
bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]